What does it mean to be brave? I'm going
to show you today why most of us do not
understand the nature of bravery and how
you can become a more courageous person.
We'll draw on the lessons of history
from real-life accounts of courage and
the fascinating neuroscience of what
happens in our brains when we are brave.
The philosopher Aristotle described
courage as one of his foundational
virtues. I have long thought of it as
the most important virtue because
without courage, how can you stand up
for the right thing? How can you pursue
your true calling? How can you be a good
leader or a good parent or a good
friend? All of these involve challenges
of courage. One reason we fail at these
challenges, we misunderstand the nature
of bravery. How can you be brave if you
don't know what bravery is?
I want to take you back to April 2017.
Trains come and go in the New York City
Subway.
On one platform in the Bronx, two trains
come to a stop.
Through the doors of one train, someone
shoots a video.
It shows a woman stuck between the
subway doors on the train on the other
side of the platform.
She holds a bag.
Her head is outside the car while her
body is caught inside.
She stands there motionless, trapped,
half in, half out,
powerless.
The video rolls.
One person walks by, moves slowly.
Another person comes along, then a
third. No one seems to be in a hurry. No
one pays any notice to the trapped
woman.
No one helps her.
The camera zooms out, then in. The
seconds tick by. It's almost unbearable.
You feel like shouting, "Do something.
Help her." An Instagram story about the
incident posted the video and featured
this message, "If you thought you were
having bad day,
just be glad this isn't you.
There's someone we are not seeing in the
video.
We're not seeing the person holding the
phone.
If you see someone in trouble and you
are shocked that people are walking by
without helping,
what does it say about you that you just
shoot a video about it?
Now, it turns out that help was on the
way.
Subway employees were trying to get the
doors open.
But the video went viral because it
spoke to a great fear that we have.
In a moment of crisis, when we are
desperate, when we are trapped, will
people walk by us without bothering to
help? Without bothering to look?
Psychologists sometimes call this the
bystander effect. Lots of people can
help in a given situation, but no one
steps forward. Everyone waits for
somebody else to fix the problem.
Lots of terrible things in our world
happen like this. In plain sight.
Many horrors in human history unfold
while the world watches and does
nothing.
A saying that is misattributed to the
Irish statesman Edmund Burke goes like
this.
All it takes for the triumph of evil is
for good men to do nothing.
But every now and then, we hear a
different kind of story. On my podcast,
I interviewed a woman named Abigail
Marsh. She told me a story.
Many years ago, Abigail is in college.
She's home for the summer visiting
family in Washington state. One night,
she goes to Seattle to have dinner with
a friend.
Around midnight, she starts to drive
home to Tacoma on Interstate 5. Yes,
it's it's a incredibly busy freeway,
very heavily trafficked. As Abigail
approaches a crest of the highway, she
sees something on the road. Somehow, a
dog is running across the freeway.
Abigail is an animal lover.
She swerves. And unfortunately, I hit it
anyways. And the combination of hitting
the dog and swerving sharply has sent my
car into a series of fishtails across
several lanes of freeway. The car begins
to spin, around and around.
Abigail is completely helpless.
It's a miracle she doesn't hit anyone.
Until finally it came to a rest in the
fast lane of the freeway facing backward
into the oncoming traffic just past the
crest of the overpass. It was the the
most terrified I've ever been in my
life.
And I remember trying over and over to
turn the car back on and I couldn't
figure out why I couldn't get the engine
to re-engage. A vehicle comes over the
crest of the overpass, straight at
Abigail. At the very last second, the
driver sees her and swerves out of the
way. Another car comes over the crest
and again swerves at the last moment.
And so my car would shake every time
these big cars and semi's would swerve
around it at the last minute. I just
knew it was a matter of time until one
of them was going to hit me. Abigail is
like that trapped woman in the subway
car. Except cars are hurtling at her.
It's at this point that something
surprising happens. A man appears at her
passenger side window. He tells her,
"Looks like you could use some help."
Abigail's first thought is to remember a
piece of advice her mom has given her.
Don't let strange men into your car. But
as more cars come wooshing over the
crest of the overpass,
she tells him she does need help.
He tells her to move over to the
passenger side seat. He waits for a
break in the traffic, races around the
car, and gets into the driver's seat. He
figures out why the car is not starting.
It's still in drive. He puts the car
into park and the engine starts up. He
waits for another break in the traffic,
guns the engine, pulls a sharp U-turn on
the interstate, and gets to an off ramp.
His car is parked on the shoulder ahead.
Yeah, I remember the sound of his voice
as he looked at me. I'm gray, I'm sure
and sweaty and shaking. I felt awful.
And he said, "You're going to be okay.
Do you need me to follow you home?" And
I said, "No, no, I'm going to be okay.
I'll be okay." You know, I wasn't
thinking quite straight in the moment.
And he said, "Okay, you take care of
yourself." And out of the car he got and
went back to his own car and drove off
into the night. And that is the last I
ever saw of him.
Abigail later pieced it together what
happened. She realizes that the man had
probably seen her stuck in the fast lane
of the highway as he came driving over
the crest of the freeway. In a split
second, he decided to pull over and
help. In the dead of night, he ran
across six lanes of highway to get to
her passenger side window. He risked his
life a second time as he ran around the
car to get into the driver's seat. And
then a third time as he gunned the
engine and pulled a U-turn to get
Abigail to safety.
At the point he made the decision to
help, he had no idea who Abigail was.
She was a stranger. Why had he risked
his life three times to save hers? This
question stayed with Abigail as she went
on to become a psychologist and a
neuroscientist. She became fascinated by
people who do brave and kind things for
others.
She started to study one particular
group of extraordinary people. People
like Lucia Lloyd.
Lucia heard a podcast episode that we
did on what are known as non-directed
kidney donors.
These are people who decide to donate a
kidney and not just to a friend or a
family member, to a total stranger. I
want to play you a note she sent us
because it's one of the best notes we
have ever received in the last decade of
producing the Hidden Brain podcast. I
really like the things that the episode
was saying about how we all want to
become more altruistic. And I was
particularly affected by the person who
said that he believed that God put us on
this earth to help people and wanted to
do what God wanted in helping other
people and I thought that's what I
believed, too. Maybe the obvious answer
to how can I be more like the people who
donate their kidney to a stranger is for
me to donate my kidney to a stranger.
And so, I am already getting started on
the process. I might very easily be
ending up to save somebody's life
because of your episode.
Why aren't more of us like Lucia? Well,
one clue to that answer is that many of
us are like Lucia when it comes to the
people we are very close to. If your
child or brother or parent needed a
kidney to stay alive,
wouldn't you donate an organ to save
them? But, here's the thing.
Would you do this for a friend? What
about a co-worker?
What about a stranger?
Most of us are affected by a phenomenon
known as social discounting. We're very
generous to the people who are closest
to us, but we become far less generous
as our connection to someone becomes a
tiny bit more remote. As Abigail began
studying altruistic kidney donors, she
found something very, very interesting.
They made little distinction between
people who were in their innermost
circle
and people who were strangers.
As Lucia said in her note to me, "I
think God put us on this earth to help
people." Notice, she didn't say, "God
put us on this earth to help the people
we are closest to."
For people like Lucia, there's not much
of a distinction between us and them.
Extraordinary altruists think that even
people they've never met deserve that
kindness and compassion.
In fact, when Abigail asked people who
were altruistic kidney donors why they
were donating their kidney to a
stranger, many of them thought the
question didn't make sense. They think
if you have two kidneys and you could
survive just fine with one, which is
true,
that if another person is going to die
unless they get your kidney, the choice
to donate to them is the obvious choice.
It feels to them so intuitive and so
clear that they have trouble
understanding why anybody wouldn't make
that decision. Abigail wanted to know if
there was something different about the
brains of the people who are willing to
go to great lengths to help strangers.
She conducted brain scans of her
altruistic kidney donors and compared
them with people who are less
altruistic. She found a difference in
the region of the brain known as the
amygdala. People who are extremely
altruistic seem to have larger amygdalas
than the rest of us. Why does that
matter? Well, one thing the amygdala
does is to help us recognize distress in
other people. Extreme altruists appear
to be more sensitive to the pain of
others. Interestingly, psychopaths tend
to have smaller amygdalas, which makes
sense given that they often fail to
recognize the distress of other people.
Now, think about the actions of people
who rush in to help during a crisis.
The ones who dive into a stormy sea to
rescue a drowning stranger.
Who dash into a burning building to save
a family trapped inside. These are
people who run toward danger when most
of us freeze or run away.
These extraordinary people are not
seeing strangers as strangers. They're
seeing them
as their own brothers and sisters.
There's a model that many of us carry
around in our heads about what it means
to be brave. We get this from the TV
shows we watch, from the movie stars we
admire. But in real life, courage looks
very different. Some years ago, the
mayor of Newark, New Jersey, Cory
Booker, was headed home from work. When
he got to his block, he saw that his
neighbor's house was on fire. His
neighbor was screaming that her daughter
was trapped inside. Without thinking,
the mayor raced into the burning house
with his security detail right behind
him. Booker plunged into the house,
fought his way through the smoke into
the bedroom where his neighbor's
daughter was barely conscious, flung her
over his shoulder, and staggered back
through the kitchen, which was engulfed
in flames at this point. Burning embers
are raining down on him, and he finally
makes it back out of the house and
collapses into the yard, where he was
taken by ambulance to the hospital with
injuries from smoke inhalation and
second-degree burns to his hands.
On CBS, Cory Booker was interviewed
afterwards.
He talked about whether he felt brave as
he ran through the burning building. It
is a very, very scary thing, and I'd
like to say that I at that point I was
feeling so courageous, but honestly, it
was terrifying. I couldn't see anything
but the flames coming out of the
kitchen. Yeah. And I really had this
moment where I thought,
"Okay, I think this is I think I'm
trapped. I think we can't get out." Cory
Booker, who went on to become a senator
from New Jersey, doesn't sound like John
Wick. He doesn't act like Tom Cruise or
Matt Damon. He doesn't sound fearless,
and that's the point. In our minds, we
have gotten courage and fearlessness
confused. When we find ourselves in a
difficult situation, and we find
ourselves frightened, we tell ourselves,
"Okay, this means I am not brave because
brave people are fearless." I cannot say
this strongly enough. That idea is
bankrupt.
It's simply not true. Courageous people
aren't courageous because they are
fearless. They're courageous because
they have expanded their circle of love.
They think of strangers the same way
they think of their children or siblings
or parents. To me, this is the great
lesson of the scientific research into
altruism. If you want to be brave, don't
ask how you can be less frightened. Ask
how you can love more. How you can love
better.
>> I want to tell you a personal story. It
doesn't involve physical courage, but it
does involve taking a big risk. When I
finished college, I received a degree in
engineering. I was all set to get my MBA
and head off to a life of corporate
riches and success. But I happened to
get a couple of months off after college
and I spent it working at a local
newspaper. I fell in love with
journalism and the delight of sharing
ideas and explaining things. When I told
my parents I was going to chuck my
engineering degree and become a
journalist, my dad was very worried. He
wondered how I would make ends meet.
Perhaps I should have been more scared,
but at that point, all I could think
about was how much I loved interviewing
people and writing stories. As the years
rolled on, many people have told me that
I was brave to set aside what I had
studied in college, to drop that MBA, to
take a gamble on a profession that
didn't have great employment prospects.
But the truth is,
I was not being brave. I was just in
love with what I was doing. Today, the
Hidden Brain podcast receives millions
of downloads every month and is featured
on more than 400 public radio stations
around the United States. In 2025 alone,
I visited 16 cities for a live tour.
Things have worked out well for me, but
it's not because I'm fearless. It's
because I found something that was
bigger than my fear.
Check out Hidden Brain on Apple or
Spotify or wherever you stream audio
podcasts and subscribe to this channel
for more ideas on how the science of the
mind can help you lead a better life.
I'm Shankar Vedantam.
See you soon.